let's go to our caller from the five
seven zero area code who's calling today
from five seven zero uh hi David hey
Hector oh great um so I I have two
questions to ask you
so the first one is that most um like
how do you gonna say like the most
serious question which is like another
question but more like a comment
actually like you know how you were
saying I'm Hispanic and you are Hispanic
as well and you know how you were saying
like you don't consider yourself to be
necessarily of color right well my skin
is where is fairly like so I'm from the
Dominican Republic Dominican Dominicans
are our darker yep at my work I have
[Music]
well not necessarily a manager but he's
like higher up on me and he just was
making messed up jokes in the workplace
about Dominicans yeah and I live in the
Northeast Pennsylvania coal area he's
from Hazelden and it was just like super
annoying and I basically took him to the
side and I was like Terry what are you
doing this is so annoying and you have
no idea how stupid you sound
yep are you sure like there's a lot
don't like to grow up from these people
around here like that are you know just
on their in their ways you know um I
don't know but um the other question or
my actual question is what are your
favorite Argentinian rock bands okay so
so I want to get back to that first
thing because it's interesting but some
Argentinian bands I like include follows
Cadillacs out then think oh they gotta
end this bedico's I saw it that's reggae
I saw them here in Boston actually look
after this is a great band there's just
so many there's so many great
Argentinian rock bands but so what what
was your co-workers reaction when you
said hey you know I I don't like I don't
like those comments that you're making
so my co-workers reaction was like dude
I understand I apologize and all this
art stuff we made did apologize but you
know I just feel like it's in a very
break way that he did that right well
it's not like you saying something is
gonna change this person's deeply held
beliefs right it might make them
moderate what they say in public but
it's not like saying one thing will
actually get them to reconsider their
views more than likely yeah absolutely
yeah I just like I wish there was a
better way for me be since we are such a
small company we don't have an HR yeah
and I wish that we there was a better
way of me being able to deal with this
right but I don't know yeah like you
know like this oh yeah all right heck
they're very good appreciate you sharing
the story it sounds horrible I've had
similar situations myself and it is it
is very very ugly I hope to hear from
you again thank you so much for the call